I just hung up the phone with somebody
that I love dearly who got disappointing
news at work and here's what I want to
tell you you are not stuck where you are
the only place that you ever get stuck
is right up here so whatever it is that
you're thinking about doing that change
you want to make the risk you want to
take do it do it because you're never
going to feel ready you're never going
to feel
confident and that's not how confidence
works that's not how life Works anyway
courage comes first you have to find the
courage to take the risk step into the
unknown and the courage to trust
yourself cuz the fact is you will figure
it out and you do deserve more and today
is the day to place that bet on yourself
and when you tap into that courage to
take the risk to take control of your
life guess what happens the confidence
follows because you start to believe in
yourself so go freaking do it